des engrenages des modèles de mécanique
les bases du projet les cordées de la
réussite
un programme national visant à favoriser
l'accès aux études supérieures
lycéens étudiants et professeurs oeuvre
dans un but commun créer un aéroglisseur
une expérience innovante apprécié par
les élèves du coup bah c'est intéressant
on fait des échanges avec les ingénieurs
de l'estaca on apprend beaucoup
moi je vais faire dans les énergies
renouvelables plus tard quand je fais ça
ici c'est juste pour me donner un peu
l'idée travailler en équipe développer
ses connaissances ou tester des
prototypes
tous les moyens sont bons pour mettre
les élèves en confiance démission de
plusieurs heures organisée par les
professeurs toutes les deux semaines
à la base c'est fait en sorte que pour
les élèves des ans des classes
populaires aient accès aux études
supérieures et surtout pour leur
ouverture d'esprit il se met en activité
ils vont participer à un projet de
d'écoles d'ingénieurs donc il y voit
qu'ils peuvent et y arriver que
finalement c'est pas trop satisfait
accessible le projet est accessible à
tous contrairement aux idées reçues sur
le métier d'ingénieur pour les étudiants
de l'association pégase estaca c'est
l'occasion de partager une nouvelle
expérience pédagogique pour le plaisir
par passion pour donner l'envié de faire
ce que l'on fait pour que les autres me
donne envie de faire ce que l'on fait
c'est vraiment un missile s'agit en fait
de mixer le savoir intellectuel savoir
manuel la maquette du prototype devrait
voir le jour entre fin mai et début juin
à condition que tous s'accordent sur le
chemin de la réussite